he's a nurse in Britain's National
Health Service and he's never struggled
as much to make ends meet chuck wood
says he's seeing colleagues leave the
profession to work in supermarkets
because the wages are better he's
staying put but he's making sacrifices
I've had to cut down on a lot of things
with the kids which I can't afford to
provide for them because of the High
Cost of Living so it's not just about
clapping for us during the pandemic I
think we need to be respected and
appreciated for what we do
now for the first time nurses in all
parts of the UK except Scotland or stage
two 12-hour strikes next month their
representative body the Royal College of
Nursing says they had no choice after
the government rejected calls for formal
talks over NHS pay the RCN says
experienced nurses are 20 worse off in
real terms compared to 2010 due to
successive below inflation pay Awards
this is not something that nurses do at
the drop of a hat it's not something
that nursing staff have ever done across
the whole of the UK in such huge numbers
so it is significant and it should be
sending a really clear message to the
government that they need to do
something Health secretary Steve Barkley
says the pay demands are not affordable
pointing to this year's rise worth four
percent on average Following last year's
three percent rise despite a general
public sector pay freeze but unions
argue that instead of investing in
current nursing staff billions of
dollars are being spent on agency
workers to plug Workforce gaps with 25
000 nursing staff leaving the NHS in the
last year you've got a lot of people
leaving because of you know being under
too much pressure for example or those
who are considering leaving they often
cite issues around not having enough
staff to do a good job for example so
you've just got a pattern of work
um which is very challenging nurses will
still provide Emergency Care during the
strikes but routine services will be hit
hard at a time when the system's already
under extreme pressure
further strikes are likely in the sector
in the coming months involving people
like Junior doctors and ambulance
workers in Scotland planned strikes have
been called off after the revolved
government came up with an offer worth
eight percent for a newly qualified
nurse but the rest of Britain is getting
ready for severe disruption Nadine
barber Al Jazeera London